uh Las Vegas has an odd collection of
museums we kind of listed some of them
earlier but you know the Mob Museum to
the burlesque Hall of Fame well now
there's a new one it's a project
downtown that looks to highlight the
loud the Rowdy the gritty world of punk
rock music
Candace Charles is a punk rocker now
live at the Museum site this morning
Candace good morning to you he didn't do
it he can't just eat it so glad you got
to singing in John very proud of you but
we gotta highlight the real artists it
was close yeah but we gotta highlight
the real Arts they have all the great
items here for punk rock history really
and you know this is just coming
together but it's been two years in the
works and I hear they're going to be
getting like the huge glasses soon to
put all of the uh artifacts in I'm
joined by the punk Ambassador Kylie now
tell me a little bit about these
clothing items here these are a few
things that we're going to see in the
museum as well right yes we are so this
is one of my favorites it's uh Angelo
from Fishbones suit and the part that I
love about it is he created this
um sash when he was on Warped Tour and
he named himself the ambassador of the
Warped lands I like that that fits right
yeah yeah I love it
uh this here is a uh oops sorry see this
is what I mean it's like I'm backwards
uh DIY
bloody
dress that's a perfect way to describe
it right yeah it's a bloody Hospital
dress worn by Theo kogan singer of the
lunatics
uh sorry the lunatics at CBGB in 1989 so
yeah so you really are going from all
different eras here with all the
different artifacts and clothing right
yeah and the next one I think is uh
really cool as well this is a pansy
division disco shimmy dress that Chris
Freeman wore at the 50th anniversary of
uh Pride oh that's awesome I love the
energy you can you can like feel the
energy in the air here really you can
last one here it's really kind of like a
punk rock just homage right real
clothing yeah it's just like classic uh
punk rock leather jacket I love it I
love it thank you so much Charlie for
chatting with us this morning we
appreciate you our Punk Ambassador and
you guys can check all of this out
yourself fairly soon as I said the
construction is underway but the opening
is going to be expected to be Friday
January 13th 2023 of course we've got
you covered with all of the details on
our website 8newsnow.com for now live
from the soon to be from Rock Museum off
of Western Avenue I'm Candace Charles 8
news now all right
[Applause]
the Ramones right there there you see
the boys I love this stuff I've been
following the punk rock museum on social
media for the last several months
actually wow and all these artists from
back in the 70s 80s they're submitting
these artifacts for the museum from
concerts they've done it's guitars it's
picks it's all sorts of different things
and even some local musicians I heard a
throw at the name Rob Ruckus who is a
punk rock legend here
that's neat I can't wait till we meet
again